welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and when the crowd say
bow select her to be the leader of
Mandalore
what Mandalorian season 3 episode 3 is
now out and this video we're breaking
down the brand new entry filled with
Easter eggs hidden details and a lot of
things that hint towards the future
we're gonna be recapping it all and
giving our thoughts on the entry heavy
spoilers ahead so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out then check out
now if you enjoy the video please hit
the thumbs up button and make sure you
subscribe to join our Hive of scum and
Billy by the way a huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
Mandalorian now last week saw Mando
traveling to the minds of mandalor in
order to cleanse himself in the Living
Waters these mines were something that
we'd seen before in the sarc air with it
being the same area that Ahsoka pursued
Darth Maul through upon reaching it as
ceremony was carried out that was
mirroring the opening of episode 1 in
which a Mandalorian was somewhat
baptized Mandel was also going through a
sort of baptism in order to wash himself
of the sins of dishonoring the children
of the watch but when he was Pulled
Under Beau had to dive in after him down
there she came eye to eye with the soul
the mythical Beast of Mandalore that was
long thought extinct it was a great
episode unless you are an IGN reviewer
who gave it 5 out of 10 because they
said the scenes were too dark brightness
buttons right there and that takes us
into episode 3.
now we begin with Beau overlooking the
waters with Mando at her side the
superstitions of Mandalore was something
that she didn't believe but after seeing
the mythosaur she's beginning to change
her mind however she still thinks that
it may have been some kind of
hallucination which is why she questions
it think deep down she's starting to go
back to the Mind state that maybe she is
the chosen one again as only she
witnessed the mythical Beast that was
said to bring with it restoration the
entry is called the convert and it very
much carries its notion to several of
the characters we have Bo converting her
beliefs back to following the Legends
Mano converts back to being a
Mandalorian that doesn't remove his
helmet and we also have Dr Pershing who
we'll talk about later on I think at the
heart of it though the converts actually
referring to Elia Kane who becomes a big
character in this episode now why is the
mythosaurus so important well when the
tone came to Mandalore they discovered a
luscious planet that offered New
Opportunities amongst their ranks was
Mandel or the great and he decided to
lead his people against the dominant
species of the planet this was the
mythosaur a gigantic Beast that dwarfed
everything else Mandalore the great was
the first person the best to beast in
combat and after his victory his people
named the planet after him who made the
soul became a symbol of the mandalorians
and mandala the great even created his
helmet out of one of the creature's
skulls this was centuries before tarvis
LaRosa with a darksaber and taming
mythosaurus has become a rite of passage
for the mandalorians now the thing with
tar vizsler was very much in between the
Civil Wars that took place on the planet
which we are very much seeing or repeat
of here Mandalore great United the
people and then they fell out and then
centuries later tarvisler did it too the
Clone Wars then saw two sides rising up
and it's clear from the whole helmet
thing that there's two sides once more I
think that the Mandalorian could very
much be following in the footsteps of
Mandalore the great and top visler in
that he might unite the people once more
or Under One Roof now the armor has
mentioned that the re-emergence of the
mythosol would usher in a new era for
them mandalorians which will likely be
led by the wielder of the darksaber she
said that the great Beast would emerge
from the waters now we're very much
watching this prophecy play out anyway
that takes in a few times a few times
it's Theory time God damn [__]
so if we look at other episodes in the
series there have been several moments
in which grogus managed to best beasts
we could potentially see this eventually
being extended to the mythosol as the
little guy becomes more and more
powerful he has stepped away from the
Jedi to travel a path of a Mandalorian
and I'd love to see him tame the beast
at some points and ride it with Mando
Ragu is poor Jedi in part Mandalorian
too so we might be very much seeing a
repeat of tar Vizsla embodied within him
anyway let's see
I see a little silhouette
we will not let you go
now Mando takes a sample of water with
him as proof that he was actually there
and he's now back to no longer removing
his helmet this is the way it seems like
a happy moment but out in space they're
sworn by Ty interceptors and though we
don't hear what grogu has to say he does
seemingly Force predict them before
their arrival it leads to an amazing
Chase with Mando using some of those
special features on her Gauntlet last
week we talked about this ship in depth
and went over all of its artillery
including these backfiring laser cannons
which work really well when being
pursued however the interceptors
constantly keep out maneuvering them
because they're more advanced in agile
ships than your typical fighter at this
moment we don't learn exactly why
they're in the area but it's possible
that the Imperials have been searching
for clues of Gideon's location either
that or they just want to make sure that
Mandalore stays under Imperial
occupation and this episode does have
its power struggles in it it takes a lot
of focus on the remnants of the
Imperials and early on we're given this
idea that they're still out there just
because my Gideon's gone it doesn't mean
that the rest are and potentially we
could be leading to a reveal of grand
Admiral thrawn who once teased out all
the way back in the a soccer episode
manner goes skydiving manages to make it
back to his N1 which is when he bursts
out a proton torpedo like what we saw
Anakin using at the end of The Phantom
Menace this is such a cool chase scene
and the show's really flexing its budget
here giving an amazing battle that goes
from space to air to land and then back
to air the N1 was designed for dogfights
like this and unibose knowledge of the
planet they're able to take them out we
get a great Top Gun maverick-esque turn
with her spinning in the air and he
wants more hammers home the idea that
bow and Mando worked great together as a
team what about the victory is
short-lived with beau's Castle being
destroyed by Thai bombers this of course
Echoes a knight of a thousand tears
which saw her other home of the sundari
being destroyed all the remnants of her
royal houses have been taken down and
now she's all that remains of her line
it's been a pretty April or Jenny for
her in all honesty but now she's free of
the confines of her past and ready to
build something new as more interceptors
swarm the area Mano suggests that they
jump somewhere they'll never be found
which is when we cut to Coruscant I'm in
the timeline I believe that we last Saw
Coruscant during the Montage at the end
of Return of the Jedi there were statues
being toppled and pulled over which even
to this day is often shown in news
footage to signify freedom and bring
down the old God in more recent shows
we've seen exactly what the city was
like during its Imperial occupation and
we of course visited in both and or in
the bad batch by that it being somewhere
that had the constant ivms looking over
everything and there's conversations
speaking out against them were often
filled with innuendo and also
suggestions process or firsthand how
Commander Cody decided to turn against
the empire there were clones regretting
killing the Jedi and Andor had a big
subplot there with the seeds of the
Rebellion now this episode Paints the
planet out in a new light with it once
more being the glistening capital of the
Galaxy that's no longer under Imperial
rule it's great seeing it like this once
more and the color is back into the
surroundings whereas it was almost
completely Stripped Away during the
Imperials occupation Imperials very much
use the color as black white and gray
throughout everything and this
translated into their uniforms too
however just as we saw how color slowly
got integrated in the bad batches
uniform after they left we see how
that's happened in the surroundings of
the planet too we go to see Dr Pershing
giving a speech and we discover that
he's been granted a second chance in the
amnesty program of the new Republic this
is somewhat similar to the real-life
Operation Paperclip in which Nazi
scientists were given jobs in the US
went up on Brown was famously part of
this and lucasfilm will be tackling this
idea again in the upcoming Indiana Jones
film now Dr Pershing is a character that
was first introduced all the way back in
episode 1 and I think it's clear he's
becoming a key character in the series
the bad batch has somewhat hinted at
what could be happening in this series
as we explore more of what was happening
with the cloneas after the destruction
of topoka City Pershing wears one of
their patches and season 2 also featured
some of their work we had Echoes of
snoke and pulp's score during these
moments so I think this is all setting
the groundwork for how somehow Palpatine
returned in the speech he discusses A
desperate individual who is intent on
using cloning technology on himself to
secure more power which is clearly
alluding to this a pushing was captured
in season 2 after Mano and crew managed
to shut down the shuttle he was
traveling on described as being a cloner
he eventually ended up giving Intel on
where kraku was located at and we of
course know this was onboard moff
Gideon's ship on board the shuttle he
was held hostage by the pilot and Carl
was taunted by him bringing up the
destruction of Alderaan and then she
shot through pershing's ear and killed
the captor pershing's ear was grazed
during this explaining why he looks the
way he does in this season like so Max
Factor contestant he gives a sub story
about his mother and how she could have
been saved if cloning technology had
have been available now call me an idiot
if I'm wrong which you might be right if
you say that but I saw this as kind of
being a metaphor for stem cell research
and they were hoping to use cloning to
help organ replacement although it does
kind of get in the whole Muddy Waters of
what rights do the clones have if they
go beyond just being organs now he
states that he wanted to help people
initially but he was drafted into the
Empire which is where his technology was
corrupted it very much shows that the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions and the Empire took good
people and turned them into monsters he
was watched over by a woman that we see
fixing an amnesty badge and at the
beginning of the scene and you might
recognize her as popping up earlier in
the season when Pershing contacted her
by hologram it was very much the idea
that the Imperials still exist and
though their converts now they're
awesome that's scheming away on how to
get more power most people don't change
their political ideologies overnight the
very much worming their way into
positions of power like Hydra didn't the
MCU Pershing is fitting in well with the
upper class though and we see that they
welcomed him in because they don't
really care about sight outside he's
created by calamari as well as an
aristocrat who talks about how he was
almost drafted he doesn't know whether
it was the Imperials or the New Republic
because he's so rich it doesn't really
matter who's in charge he's still Rich
so he's pretty Untouchable and it kind
of comments to how it's the lower
classes that have to give up everything
when it comes to war at this point he's
given a ride in a taxi and the driver
begins to bring up the Skydome botanical
gardens first mentioned in Republic
Commando True Colors these were used as
the headquarters of the order of the
counted Circle this group were a bunch
of Elites and it was basically the Star
Wars equivalent of the Freemasons highly
exclusive this contained a range of
wealthy and influential individuals
which could be why the Droid suggesting
that Pershing should visit there
probably reading into that as the Droid
also talks about the museum and we see
that he's dropped off at the amnesty
housing which is a far cry from The
Glitz and glamor that he's just
experienced he ends up chatting with
some ex-officers including the woman he
used to give orders to a moth Gideon
ship all of them use Alpha numericodes
and this is clearly so they don't know
who the others are gives them a clean
slate anonymity and it also means they
can't snitch on each other for being
complicit in war crimes the higher-ups
were of course famous amongst the imps
and thus knowing their names might put
them in danger in this new program
anyway we hear the rumors surrounding
moth Gideon including that he escaped on
his way to a war tribunal which again is
a call back to the second world war the
Nuremberg trials were held in the
aftermath of the conflict and these held
Nazis to account for their horrendous
acts there's also the theory that he was
hooked up to a mind player which isn't
it's not a reference to stranger things
as this was actually in the Star Wars
Universe this was a device that people
were terrified of and it was first
mentioned in episode 8 of the
Mandalorian as Kara thought she might be
uploaded to one however the Galactic
Empire denied all knowledge of their
existence but the soldiers talking about
it yeah makes it seem like it existed
and they also discuss how this isn't the
way the Empire would have handled taking
people in from the opposite side and
Darth Vader probably would have been
smashing them like the like button up
against the wall however they do some
would have their freedom limited and
they talk about missing the lights of
hyperspace which we later learn is
because they're restricted to a
perimeter they reminisce about the good
old days like getting biscuit and though
they say the Empire's gone they're
laughing away when they're thinking
about it ah all those people we murdered
and that night we see as Dr Pershing
returns to his apartment on the monitor
we can hear that coruscans referred to
as an ecumenopolist which is a word that
comes from ancient Greece this means a
worldwide city which is pretty much what
coruscan is because it's a never-ending
in its skyscrapers and monuments now
initially you might think someone's been
playing Nucky nine doors on him but he's
been given a package of those delicious
yellow biscuits that you'd sell your
soul for it's clearly trying to remind
him of the good old days and what he's
Left Behind travel biscuits have popped
up in the cannon before though they did
look different to what we have here and
the next day we cut him at work and
discover he's doing menial data entry
jobs this is very much like Khan Andor
who was of course also a disgraced
employee now we see a Twilight and also
a Droid going about delivering things
pushing just wants to be left alone but
we slowly see how the Allura returning
to his work ends up betting him into
entrapment an idea goes on somewhat of a
date filled with Star Wars plays on
classic iconography like ice cream cones
and magic tricks huge alerts to Super
spider 115 on Twitter for pointing out
that the man doing the magic trick with
the dragon is reminiscent of dream
finder and his Dragon pigment from the
Disney parks we also learned that the
Lolly is called of bolt on fizzle
because well it looks like a photon
torpedo I didn't say all the Easter eggs
would be good again it's a wash with
color and vibrancy and no Pershing sees
the positives he is a bit good that his
work remains unfinished Elia Kane
Thompson with the idea of continuing his
work and says that following orders is
what got them into trouble in the first
place but following orders is something
that the Germans uses an excuse during
the Nuremberg trials and it's also a
line that's popped up throughout a lot
of the Star Wars shows good searches for
the waters could soldiers follow orders
just follow orders good soldiers follow
orders it's possible that the name Elia
Kane is also referenced to Elias Kane a
U.S senator who according to the records
was pro-slavery do you know if that's a
time with the character but the names
are pretty similar anyway something
bubbles away under the surface and this
is shown symbolically in the mountain
peak that Kane ends up taking him to
this the peak of the natural world in
corusand and beneath the surface lies
the true face amongst this natural
environment lots of beautiful things
have sprung up that have pushed this
further down I think that Kane took him
here because cloning is a natural as
well much like the city that spans a
landscape around them however it's built
on the natural world to surpass it which
is an idea that she's trying to plant in
his mind as she's revealed to be a new
Republic spy who's testing these
Imperials I think the Temptation she's
offering up is to see whether he can
stay on the right track he goes to touch
the tip of the mountain and symbolically
in storytelling this represents
achieving a goal however it Out Of Reach
much like how finishing his research is
he stopped shot by a machine commanded
by the Republic which metaphorically
shows how they're stopping his movements
in the new Republic skyscraper we see
him getting somewhat of an interrogation
this is to make sure that he's kept on
the right track reminded me a lot of the
opening of Blade Runner and he asks if
he can still pursue his cloning ideas
this is shut down though much like him
attempting to touch the Mountaintop it
shows that every aspect of his life is
controlled still and causes him to lash
out further pushing still sees the
benefits in cloning though and again he
wants to pursue it he sees it as being
something that can be a positive in the
hands of the new Republic but they are
basically wings of the same bird and who
knows if it would eventually be twisted
pushing is off but a new lab by Kane but
he turns us down because he'd have to
leave the perimeter we then returned to
his work the next day and see him
protesting Imperial equipment being
destroyed the guy pushing carts again is
weighing in on it and though he seems
like some of a lowly worker I'm telling
you mate another spy he's another
[__] spy don't trust
now Pershing then tucks into some
biscuits showing a turn in his mind and
he's once more interrogated which shows
a clear change in how he feels he
touches his ear and this is something
that he did during the opening speech as
well this is when he promised his
intentions were good which is very much
echoing what he's doing here now that
night he ends up going to g68 and saying
you son of a [__] I'm in g68 also
played gentura and quantumania as well
which it's not really connected it's
just something I noticed it's not
connected at this point he puts down his
coat with the identification badge on it
these were probably brought in to be
similar to something like the Star of
David in that it clearly identified
someone as the other might be brought in
to show how the new Republic also
operate in similar ways the Imperials
and Pershing would of course be
persecuted if he was caught doing what
he's doing now he and Kane make their
way further out and the paranoia arises
within him he feels like everyone is
watching him Raz Kane is completely
relaxed this is obviously because she's
a neuropublic spy you wouldn't have to
worry if they got caught Tong stays am I
right now even though we're Tong's days
comes from the tongs which was the third
day of the week the tongs were the
species that first invaded Mandalore
Mandalore the great was one of them and
as I've been saying I've been telling
you it's all connected
pushing looks about the train it's
almost like he feels free but when the
ticket inspector comes in they have to
get up and move we see how the cars are
held together and this is by energy
binders similar to what's used on Pod
racer engines the train per shooter is
very slow but its tenses I love watching
the droids slowly pacing towards them
almost like the Terminator they hit the
end of the line but then decide to jump
and this requires Pershing to trust in
Kane
there's several Clues like this
throughout where she's trying to
manipulate the situation around her and
even her putting the badge in at the
beginning sure that she was trying to
fit in now they jump off and die
instantly which should have happened
because they're going like 900 miles an
hour however they arrive in the
scrapyard which creates similar
iconography to planets like bracka from
the game pool in order Star Destroyer
graveyards have also popped up in the
bad batch too and they were the perfect
places for Scrappers to lose ships it's
very much a trip down memory lane for
Pershing and this is once more reminding
him of the life he left behind only the
Cockroaches remain and though this bug
isn't one of them it kind of shows
exactly what kind of man that Pershing
is cockroaches are known survivors much
like Pershing and how he stayed alive
throughout all of this political outcry
they introduced themselves and use their
names with a liar then shaking his hand
I've just realized that her name's Elia
as well so might be a play onwards a
very bad pun if it is either way this is
to gain his trust and it's a technique
that a lot of people use to get someone
on their side they then make it to the
lab and punishing serverjoyed by being
brought back he talks about how his
mother was a doctor and it's clear that
she's massively influenced his life we
hear noises on the ship which Kane
downplays again but she of course knows
that the new Republic's closing in and
they make a break for it which is when
they're captured lots of flashes of the
ending of Donnie Brasco and Kane like
Kane and Abel turn on her brother she
hands the equipment he picked out and
pershing's arrested and then uploaded to
a device similar to electroshock therapy
this was used to try and all this
someone's mind State and Pershing states
that this is actually the Mind player
the doc says it's not though and it
gives a long alphanumeric designation it
shows how the new Republic is basically
similar to the Empire they just use
nicer language take that political
commentary how you like but yeah I think
it's pretty on the nose and that it's
very much both sides are [__] okay is
congratulated over taking him in but she
clearly has this darker side to her as
she baited him into it I don't know what
her end goal is but this happening could
push him further into the Empire's side
she clearly is extremely sadistic and
turns the voltage up as a way to punish
him whether she's doing this for revenge
or to drive him further in I don't know
but I tend to lean more towards the
former this is why names are of course
kept secret so that people couldn't be
punished but she's found a way to enjoy
it as she Chomps down on the biscuit
lots of things likely happen in the
Empire and she did sort of giving her
tour to Childhood and this is her
clearly enacting her revenge with her
new powers now we cut back to Manuel and
Beau with a former taking her to the
Mandalorian audience that we saw at the
start of the Season we see tarvisler at
this point and in the series he's voiced
by John Favreau it is possible that they
might go back on the whole helmet thing
and eventually he may and mask and show
his face a figure of tar with his mask
off was released showing John's face
which may just be a special edition
thing or it may be spoiling an eventual
reveal Amanda has brought with him the
truth about the Living Waters but this
is brushed to the side by tar who also
calls Beau and Night Owl these were a
group of female Mandalorian Warriors
that were led by her that were a sect of
the death watch which he was once a part
of both are labeled apostates but the
Living Waters have cleansed them and
Mana of course also carries the
darksaber with him the darksaber has a
long back and forth history of being
possessed by the person who's seen as
the leader of the mandalorians however
in order to be its rightful owner you
have to win it in combat so far from
what we've seen in the Saga it was
originally held by Tom visler and then
it's descending previously held it
during the Clone Wars we then learn from
him that it was stolen from the Jedi
Temple during the Old Republic before
Darth Maul then won it in combat against
pree Moreland took it to deathmere which
is when Sabine ran came across it and
she gave it to Bo before moth Gideon
took it from her Manda beaten off Gideon
in combat which is why he now wields it
so technically if Bo wants it back she's
gonna have to go head to head with him
now Sabine technically didn't have to
win it in combat because she just came
across it which is why there wasn't
really an issue when she gave it to Beau
however because Bo hadn't beaten anyone
to take it she wasn't really respected
and she didn't end up uniting Mandalore
as had been promised now this is why Bo
refused to take it at the end of the
Mandalorian season 2 when Mando offered
it up to her it would just be a repeat
of the cycle and huge it out to Ryan
Arie bloody Ryan Arie or pointing out
the similarities between this and Game
of Thrones by the end of the series Jon
Snow and Daenerys were working together
and they were very similar in Dynamics
to Mando and Beau Mandos are into ruling
like John was and Dany believed it was a
Birthright just like Bo so you kind of
have these two sides and though they are
forming an alliance at this point
if they both want the darksaber there's
only one way it can go anyway they're
taken into the back with the armaire
which is where they present the water
and much like holy water it's poured
into a bowl recreating this idea of
baptism din is redeemed along with Bo
and they're now accepted by the rest of
the group this is the way Beau is
brought in once more and even though we
we can't see her face I can imagine that
she's smiling Under The Helmet she was
someone who was abandoned by her
followers her home was destroyed but she
now has a family in the Fast and Furious
sense of the word now a big question at
this point is is Mandalore even worth
saving the fusion bombs had hit the
planet destroy the major structures like
the sundari and he turned it into a land
of glass-like structure Mandalore used
to be a luscious Planet but due to the
Millennia of Civil War it turned it into
this almost inhospitable Wasteland both
sister Satine wanted the mandalorians to
become pacifists rasbo on the other side
definitely didn't want that to happen
this was all part of the death watch and
Judah all the constant Wars basically
the inability for them to get along you
do start to think should the
mandalorians be extinct not being racist
there by the way that isn't me being
racist
anyway that wraps up the entry and on
Twitter I'm kind of seeing a lot of back
and forth with people being like why did
we have to have 37 minutes of doctor
Pershing personally I liked it um it was
something a bit like Sean Connery there
but I do enjoy when TV shows pick a side
character and go into their thoughts and
feelings it's always a risk when they do
that though as you are going to alienate
some of the audience and possibly bore
them but I think this buildup on the
themes of Ando perfectly and discussed
the side of the Empire that we don't
often see maybe we're the bad guys if
you're a fan of the new Republic and
yeah there's just lots of Darker things
going on on both sides clearly so yeah I
like those moments and you know even if
you didn't I think that the opening of
the entry is at least gonna get people
on board it just depends what you want
from a Star Wars show and I think that
when they take time to explore
characters like this that it really adds
to the lore so yeah let me know your
thoughts below are you excited for next
week or did this kind of kill the vibe
for you due to its different pace we are
in competition right now and giving away
the Superman 4K box set to 3 subscribers
on the 15th of April and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
you pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now say
that to you then message me on Twitter
at heavy spoilers you want some else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of The Last of Us finale which
will be linked on the screen right now
50 minutes of the most in-depth Easter
eggs you've ever seen very proud of the
video and if you love the series then go
check it out after this by the way
thanks for saying through the breakdown
I've been poor and I'll see you next
time take care peace